These people
are challenging themselves
to stay underwater
for as long as possible.
Some go for half a day
while others
manage to spend
an entire week fully submerged.
What would happen
to your body
if you tried this challenge.
Would your skin fall off?
On today's challenge,
we're going to find out.
In 2006,
David Blaine challenged himself
to be underwater
for a full seven days.
He trained with the Navy SEALs
to lose 23 kg (50 lb),
so his body
would require less oxygen.
But we're dropping you
into this challenge
right away,
with no training at all.
Is this something
you'd be able to handle?
The moment you go underwater,
you'd use less oxygen and
therefore could stay
submerged longer.
As your heart slowed down,
your blood would be diverted
to essential organs that
need oxygen the most,
like your brain,
heart and,
kidneys.
This shunting
is called
peripheral vasoconstriction.
Okay, you're thirty seconds in.
At this point,
you would want to breath again.
You could keep holding your breath
for two minutes
if you’re trained for
underwater emergencies but,
past that time,
you’ll need to be
assisted by a breathing device.
If you're a free diver,
you'd be able to keep going
for more than 10 minutes.
To do so,
you would have expelled
carbon dioxide out of your lungs
by hyperventilating.
Okay, now that your body
is saturated with oxygen
you'd want to avoid any activity
in order to slow down
your heart rate.
Just stay still as much as possible.
After a five-minute
exposure to water,
your skin would prune,
especially your fingers and toes.
These aquatic wrinkles happen
because of the narrowing
of blood vessels in your skin.
This shrinking
is called digital vasoconstriction
But,
this is nothing
you haven't experienced before.
Let's keep going.
If you spent these
past twenty minutes
without any breathing device
there's a high chance
you'd experience brain damage.
The steady build-up of
carbon dioxide in your blood
would turn it
into an acidic brew.
Muscle spasms
and disorientation could follow,
as well as
a racing heart
and ultimately,
death.
So, to avoid all that,
you'll need a scuba tank
if you have
any hope of
finishing this challenge.
Okay, now that you have some
pure oxygen,
you think this challenge
will be easier right?
Well,
I’m not that sure.
After seven hours
of soaking,
you could suffer from hypothermia.
If the water temperature
drops below
your body temperature
would dip down to
or lower.
You'd start to shiver,
and your pulse would be weak
The cold would
affect your organs,
especially your heart
and nervous system.
You could eventually
go unconscious.
With no warm-up,
hypothermia can lead
to your entire respiratory system
shutting down
and your death.
So for your survival,
the water temperature
should be kept around
Okay, after 24 hours of
of underwater life.
you’ll notice some bubbles
forming on your skin.
These are known as vesicles.
They develop because
water becomes trapped
between your outer
and middle layers of skin.
They will continue to form
the longer you stay in the water,
and eventually burst.
And now,
as you finally
finish this challenge,
and get out of the water,
your skin
would start to
peel away
from the popped vesicles.
You'd need medical attention
immediately
as you'd likely have
a severe headache
along with other health issues.
Okay sure,
you managed to make it
out of this challenge alive but
it definitely wouldn't be worth it.
If you want to relax,
I've heard
that withstanding the cold
can enhance your well-being.
Want to give it a try?
Okay,
we'll see what that challenge brings
on another episode of